the Teen Titans are starting to grow up
the first look at the series from San
Diego comic-con left many DC fans
surprised to how bleak the show looks
compared to its contemporaries at the CW
but there's a reason why that trailer
was so dark and gritty and it has a lot
to do with the growth of each of the
individuals Titan characters launching
in fall 2018 Titans is a flagship series
of the new streaming platform DC
Universe set to bring exclusive DC
Comics content to viewers no matter what
device they're on it's a major expansion
of DC properties on TV whether they're
animated or live-action and Titans is
just one part of it Titans may not have
the sunny disposition of the CW's flash
Supergirl or legends of tomorrow and it
might be even more angsty than arrow but
that doesn't have to be a bad thing
taking on its own terms
DC's Titans just might have what it
takes to blow you away the jaded Grayson
the most controversial moment in the
Titans trailer was obviously Robins
f-bomb the apparent shift away from the
relatively carefree Teen Titans tone
bothered many but the show's not
necessarily as melodramatic as that
trailer moment makes her appear like
time is the most serious time to fight
crime speaking to polygon Titans writer
and executive producer Jeff Jones broke
down what exactly Robins angsty issue
with Batman might be and what it means
for the DC Universe show John said the
trailer shows a piece of the tone of the
show the show's not Oliver if you look
at when Robin first left Batman in the
comics there was a lot of uneasiness on
him being lost feitshans is really a
series about these different characters
that are all lost in their lives while
the phrase may not have hit the right
note with a lot of funds it does a quick
job of establishing a more complex Robin
than the Boy Wonder many a used to for
casual consumers of pop culture who have
never picked up a comic book Batman's
sidekick has often come off as a vexing
kid-brother type
[Music]
I want a car chicks dig a car titans
pushes against his perception showing a
Robin with a chip on his shoulder to
move out of Batman's shadow and possibly
become his own hero was Nightwing he has
to acknowledge that shadow and wrestle
with it and that's the kind of journey
that can only enfold over a whole season
not just a single one liner the outlaw
one of the most promising things we
learned about Titans at comic-con didn't
show up in the trailer and that's the
involvement of Jason Todd the second DC
Comics character to take up the mantle
of Robin Jason Todd is more popularly
known as a violent hero red hood who
stars in the series Red Hood and The
Outlaws but long before he two-fisted
pistols and ran with the likes of
bizarro Todd was a loyal ally to Batman
a job which ended when he was brutally
but temporarily killed by the Joker
whether you love Jason Todd or hates him
the character is a linchpin in some of
DC's most successful comic-book stories
including death in the family under the
hood and hush he's also another example
of the way in which Batman hangs over
this new series letting lower-tier
characters fight it out in a world
that's already been defined by more
marquee heroes new worlds the thing
about shared universe is you've got to
be pretty careful about not toppling all
the dominoes over every time you add a
new piece Marvel Cinematic Universe now
includes 20 movies and half as many TV
shows restricting the kinds of stories
that can be told at any given moment
DC's own arrow vs. 4 shows under growing
with Constantine getting a retroactive
inclusion Batwoman set to join the
universe and the black lightning just
waiting in the wings for a real
crossover it's a lot to keep in mind for
any screenwriter Titans on the other
hand is new territory as of now we don't
know how Titans will connect to other DC
properties are already exist or if it
even well at all with DC Universe
rolling out multiple live-action shows
and Doom Patrol Swamp Thing and star
girl it seems possible that the
streaming services shows will be their
own shared universe with Titans serving
as the start of something now the
multiverse that's true oh yeah big time
I still can't believe it and I'm from
another planet a clean slate means no
baggage and theoretically no
restrictions the writers of Titans have
a rich selection of DC heroes villains
stories and locales to choose from
if it accidentally contradicts something
from a show that came before quality
sauce well the trailer made Titans look
like the show was betraying the source
material the truth is that the show's
producers are taking inspiration from
the very best in Titans comic history
speaking to polygon Geoff Johns said the
inspiration for Titans first season
comes from what he calls the greatest
comic book Titans run ever the 1980s New
Teen Titans stories by Marv Wolfman and
George Perez the influence on the story
can be seen in the trailer which shows
Raven doing whatever she can to win
Robin to her side just like in the
Wolfman Perez comics Raven is the one
who brought the team together to fight
her demonic father Trigon we don't know
for sure if that villain will appear in
the show but considering the trailer
appears to be all about fighting inner
demons it wouldn't be surprising if
Ravens babbles the first season's a big
bird the wolf man Perez New Teen Titans
run had a major influence on DC Comics
and the comics in general 3 DC mainstays
and cyborg Raven and Starfire were all
introduced it was in the pages of that
series that Dick Grayson went from being
Robin to Nightwing and also brought the
world Slade Wilson aka Deathstroke Doom
Patrol joining the Titans on DC Universe
or the team that's been dubbed the
world's strangest heroes the Super Hero
Squad known as Doom Patrol first
conceived in the 60s the title found a
truly unusual voice in the 1980s and the
writer Grant Morrison who took the reins
starting with the series 19th issue
under Morrison's watched the comic
brought in a truly eclectic group of
characters to root for from the reality
altering muscle man flex meant Arlo to
Danny the street an entity of sentient
geography we don't know exactly what
version of Doom Patrol we'll be getting
on TV but we do know several of its
members will be showing up in Titans
first that series has already cast
actors for a Laster girl robot man
negative man and a teams leader dr.
Niles the chief colder in the comics
Beast Boy was an early member of Doom
Patrol
so it's possible he'll be used as a
connection between the teams there is a
chance that some of titans stars might
end up on the Doom Patrol show so you're
going to want to get in on the ground
floor to see this as of now we only know
that titans is premiering in the fall
with Doom Patrol set to join the
services programming lineup in 2019 if
you sign up quickly enough that you'll
be able to get 15 months of access for
the price of one year which works out to
less than $5 a month
left a link to the upcoming DC Universe
service in the description of this video
you might even get beta access to the
platform and get a shot at seeing Titans
before anybody else doorways to anywhere
speaking to polygon Geoff Johns said
that one of the goals of the first Titan
season is to demonstrate that the show
can go anywhere not just down grim back
alleys according to Jones we really
wanted to lean into the idea that every
Titan is a doorway into another genre
with Rachel aka Raven is the
supernatural in the horror and the first
season really focuses on who Raven is
and how the Titans galvanize around her
you can see that tone in the trailer
clearly viewed that way it makes sense
that the Raven centric first trailer
would have a large amount of gothic
darkness with the other characters
opening up doorways to different story
opportunities being an alien Starfire
would seem to offer a way into science
fiction and space opera stories while
Robin gives us the same world of noir
mysteries as one time mentor Batman as
the series progresses and more members
enter the fold we're likely to be given
keys to even more worlds and tones of DC
the Titans can solve mysteries in Gotham
City fight demons and other dimensions
or blast off into the Stars one way or
another the show is a lot more to offer
than just one trailer can show you the
DC Universe is just beginning and Titans
is leading the church
[Music]